amy schumer's tipping point they said  that amy wants you know wants to make  sure you get this tip and it was for a  thousand dollars and my my heart drops  Schumer left this generous gratuity  after a weekend showing of Hamilton the  musical in New York on Monday the bar  staff told ET they were left speechless  by the heck II tip on a $77 tab she she  did this I mean she she grew up in New  York she grew up bartending and  supporting herself before she made it  big and I think if she had been in our  places she would have appreciated just a  flood the comedian had enjoyed a low-key  night on Broadway with boyfriend then  Panish I'm you just asked for the drinks  and it was like three double wines and a  Sam Adams for intermission um he's  really nice and I'm like you're enjoying  the show and he goes yeah of course the  Grateful Hamilton bartenders had this  message to share with Amy it made our  night it made our week like we don't  have the words